I'm so happy Courtney decided to host
Christmas Eve but they're still deciding
where they want to spend Christmas
morning it's gonna be interesting it's
like the Battle of the Christmas morning
it's like who's gonna win oh oh it's the
Battle of Christmas morning yeah
apparently that's a thing for the
kardashian-jenner
and also making it like super kid like
all about the kids I'm there to get in a
sneak peek at the upcoming episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kourtney
Khloe and Kylie butt heads over how the
fam should spend Christmas morning my
goal is to make it a little bit more
homey instead of over this hobby
commercial like Ralph Lauren we brought
some ideas okay would handle I love well
I just love how homey our old ones were
even a that's what I said Kourt
graciously offered to host the family's
annual Christmas Eve party but what she
really wants is Christmas morning at her
place so I missed the Christmas morning
talk Kourtney's not giving this up it
really means a lot to me and I would
love to keep it at my house more than
the party I don't care to have the party
at my house but I'm happy to if you guys
you're on it there in swoops Kylie who's
not exactly here for courts reindeer
games I know no one agrees and no one
cares but I'm gonna do my Christmas
morning I like my house and then meet
you guys people won't store me by
herself not with her cousins it just
doesn't make sense that Santa goes only
goes to Courtney's house yeah
Kylie's here to deck her own halls guys
the best part about Christmas morning
for me growing up was Santa just at your
house like that's why you love it at
your house
yeah it's like the same thing I just
want that for me and Chloe she's on
court sleigh I mean side sorry guys I
can't help myself with all these
Christmas puns for me for selfish
reasons it's just me and true so I'm
like
it's just big old family you have 12
million friends that stay with you and
sometimes you're telling me Stas won't
be with you you have people Tristan I
mean he's working yeah so then I'm like
Santa visits our house that's what it's
gonna be
oh damn she just said that's what it's
gonna be that's what it's gonna be note
to self don't ever jingle Kylie's bells
perhaps it's that boss attitude that
made her a 22 year olds freaking
billionaire I'm having fun anyway Chloe
had a point about Kylie having 12
million friends around the house all the
time
especially her bestie Stassi while the
makeup mogul has been in quarantine amid
the corona virus pandemic is happy self
quarantine she's had a lot of fun with
her BFF the two hung out at Kylie's
brand-new 36 point five million dollar
la crash pad on Monday where they lounge
by the pool danced worked venom two
Tigers they snacking and tik-tok their
asses off this is a blend of your people
this is not the land
this is Glendale they totally trolled
Kylie's famous family by recreating some
iconic keeping up scenes like that one
my diamond earring came up and the ocean
is fun
[Music]